are you coughing anything up at the
moment no nothing at all so it's a dry
cough yeah but right
right here as a motivational speaker my
Dr Eisner relies on his voice and is
constantly traveling a chest pain meant
a 60 year old needed a quick prognosis
it was an NHS GP couldn't provide
I've got a chest infection and I knew
I'd have to call the doctor you've got
to make sure you're on the phone at
eight o'clock exact and I was number 31
in line well I'm not waiting for three
and a half hours and eventually I got
through to be told I've got to wait for
someone to call me back so I can explain
to them what the process is and the
earliest will be the 21st of February
a consultation at this private surgery
in North London costs up to a hundred
pounds the doctor in charge does not
believe paying to see a GP should be the
norm as former Health secretary Saji
Javid is proposing along with charging
for a e visits okay GPS are seeing
bigger problems things that have been
held onto for too long in the end that's
going to cost the NHS much much more
money we need to look at the whole
system who's going to do the
administration for these charges are we
going to turn patients away who don't
have money we need to get to the core of
what is going on across all parties
discussion and get the patients seen Mr
Javid wrote in the times we should look
on a cross-party basis at extending the
contributory principle this conversation
will not be easy but it can help the NHS
ration its finite Supply more
effectively
emulating Islands charges he wants to
build on a vision set out recently on
Sky News to relieve the burden on the
NHS having worked up close now with the
health service and you know I I don't
think the the model of the NHS as it was
set up some 70 years ago is is
sustainable for the future you know that
the world has changed and the NHS has
not moved on
you've got a lot of information going on
in your life while Mr Javid wants a
mean-tested scheme to protect those on
low incomes critics fear Healthcare
would become less accessible for people
in need of quick treatment fast
effective Speedy intervention is really
really important so what we'd see is I
think people getting delayed care the
health outcomes as a result their
probability of dying avoidably becoming
much worse much higher and of course the
impact that the the health condition of
its if it's progressed then has on their
wider life that being much more severe
as well
Downing Street says Sanji javid's
proposals are not currently being
considered but for patients like Nigel
Reisner a speedy diagnosis only comes
from paying for a GP rather than waiting
for an appointment on a stretched NHS
Rob Harris Sky News